NARRATOR: Beyonce.
Barbara Streisand.
Judy Garland.
J-Lo.
Lady Gaga.
What do they all have in common?
"A Star Is Born."
The story Hollywood
has remade five times.
Here's why.
"A Star Is Born" tells
the story of a rising star
and her troubled A-list mentor.
They develop a
romantic relationship
that quickly turns tragic.
And then--
[gasps]
NARRATOR: It all starts in
1932 with a movie called,
"What Price Hollywood."
Different name, yes, but
the exact same story.
So much so that the
director, George Cukor,
turns down the job for the
first "A Star Is Born."
That version released
in 1937, starring Janet
Gaynor and Frederic March.
The film went on
to be a success.
It won the Oscar for
Best Original screenplay
and was nominated
for six others.
In 1942, Judy Garland
starred in a radio adaptation
that she wanted to
bring back to Hollywood.
After 10 years of
campaigning, in 1954
she finally got George
Cukor to sign on.
And then the story sat
dormant until 1976.
Barbra Streisand shook
things up by taking
the film from the world of
movies into the world of music.
She wanted to play the
role opposite Elvis,
but had to settle for
Kris Kristoffersson.
It took home the Oscar
for Best Original Song
and was nominated in three
other technical categories.
In promoting the movie,
Streisand remarked that it
seems to work every 20 years.
And like clockwork, 1998.
What followed was a decade
of high profile false starts
and rumors.
It started with a possible
remake starring Will Smith
and Whitney Houston,
which turned
into Will Smith
and Jennifer Lopez,
then Jamie Foxx and
J-Lo, Russell Crowe
and Beyonce, Leonardo
DiCaprio and Beyonce,
Tom Cruise and Beyonce.
And then finally, in 2018, a
new version starring Bradley
Cooper and Lady Gaga premiers.
Each film was
reflective of its time,
but all carry the same message.
Roger Ebert once
said, it portrays
Hollywood as very
glamorous, but also
a very cruel place as well.
Some things never change.
ANNOUNCER: March On.
Celebrating women
who change the world.